[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من الرياض
والتي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار وملفات
السعوديه والخليج نبدا بالعناوين
القضاء الايراني
بالدعوه للاضراب
صحيح
قد يحقق اسرع اقتصادات العالم نموا على
حساب الهند
تجمع مياه الامطار داخل احياء سكنيه في
السعوديه يجدد مطالب رفع معايير تنفيذ
مشاريع بناها التحتيه
في الرابعه ايضا
مستشفى التخصصي بالرياض يكشف عن عملتي
زراعه قلبين لطفلتين خلال 24 ساعه
ومركز الاحصاء الخليجي يكشف عن انخفاض عدد
سكان دول الخليج بمليون نسمه خلال عام
مساء الخير نقلات صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن
المدير التنفيذي لمركز حقوق الانسان في
ايران هذه غيمه قوله انا تنفيذ عمليات
الاعدام التي جرت بحق اربعه متظاهرين حتى
الان لم تتم من خلال اجراءات القضائيه بل
قتلوا على يد لجنه خارج نطاق القانون
يتعرضون في كثير من الاحيان للتعذيب
الجسدي والنفسي ويجبرون على الاعتراف تحت
التهديد واكد المدير التنفيذي لمركز حقوق
الانسان في ايران ان النظام يستخدم عمليات
الاعدام والقوه المميته ضد المتظاهرين في
الشوارع لبث الرعب في قلوب المواطنين كما
صرحت عضو لجنه متابعه اوضاع المحتجزين
شيفا نزار هاري ان اكثر من 80 شخص يواجهون
حاليا تهاما قد تؤدي الى عقوبه الاعدام
مشيره الى ان ثمانيه اشخاص اخرين ما زالوا
ينتظرون تنفيذ حكم الاعدام بحقهم
القضاء الايراني اعلن اصدار احكام بالسجن
لفترات متفاوته ضد اربعه اشخاص بسبب
دعوتهم الى الاضراب وذلك دعما للاحتجاجات
الشعبيه التي تشهدها البلاد منذ وفاه مهس
امينه وقال مسؤول السلطه القضائيه في
محافظه هرمزكان مجتبي قهرمانه ان القضاء
اصدر الاحكام الابتدائيه بحق اربعه اشخاص
حظوا السائقين على الاضراب في ديسمبر
احدهم حكم عليه بالسجن 10 اعوام واخر خمسه
اعوام لتشكيل مجموعه تعمل على الاساءه الى
امن البلاد
منور
[موسيقى]
قالت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه ان القوات
الروسيه تعزز دفاعتها في منطقتي زبرجه
وتحسب لهجوم كبير من قوات كييف مرجحه ان
يشكل تحقيق القوات الاوكرانيه لتقدم كبير
في زابوريجيا تحديا للجسر البري الروسي
والذي يربط منطقه رستوبر الروسيه وشبه
جزيره القرم
قوات فاجنر سنه
هجمات عديده على مدينه وليدار في المحور
الشمالي من مقاطعه والتي تحتدم فيها
المعارك وتسيطر القوات ايضا على مواقع
شمال المدينه وشرقها وجنوبها مطوقه بلده
سوليدار ومدينه باخمود
المعارك الضاريه دفعت القوات الاوكرانيه
للانسحاب من منطقه شمال بخموت
كشفت وكاله انباء بلومبرج الدوليه عن
توقعاتها بان يفقد اقتصاد الهند لقبل اسرع
نموا لتحويل السعوديه محلها وتحقق النمو
بمعدل
7.6 بالمئه نتيجه ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه
الاحتياطي الهندي عن توقعاته للنمو وذلك
بنسبه 6.8 بالمئه بنهايه مارس من العام
الجاري 20 23
ينضم الينا في الاستوديو الكاتب الاقتصادي
الدكتور علي الحازمي اهلا بك معنا دكتور
اذا السعوديه تنتزع صداره النمو الاقتصادي
من الهند من سؤالي ما هي الركائز او ما هي
العوامل التي ادت لهذه الصداره الاقتصاد
السعودي
والاصلاحات الماليه ايضا هي تلعب دور كبير
ومهم لا نستطيع عزل هذه الاصلاحات عما
يحدث من نمو اقتصادي طبعا انا اتحدث عن
اصلاحات اقتصاديه من حيث السهوله الاعمال
من حيث الصلاحات اقتصاديه تنظيميه
وتشريعيه نتحدث ايضا عن اصلاحات ماليه
ترتكز بشكل كبير على الاستدامه الماليه
وهذا حقق هذا النمو الاقتصادي ايضا انا
اعتقد ان اسعار النفط لعبه الدور كبير مهم
الاوضاع الجيو السياسيه كان لها دور محرك
مهم في ارتفاع اسعار النفط كانت هي تتحدث
عن حقيقه الارادات النفطيه مثلا في العام
20 22 وصلت الى مستويات 6 اعتقد و42 مليار
ريال هذا رقم جيد وكبير كان كثير باحداث
هذا التحرك في النمو الاقتصادي اذا نظرنا
هذه يعني على جانب المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اذا قارن الوضع الاقتصادي
للمملكه مع الوضع الاقتصادي للهند من حيث
الان نقارن من حيث النمو والاقتصادي ما
حدث في بدايه العام 20 22 كانت هناك
توقعات ان الهند يحقق اعلى نمو اقتصادي
ولكن ربما عندما اتت السياسات النقديه
المتشدده التي يمارسها البنك الفيدراني
ايضا حقيقه
تضخم حدث هناك تغيير لنظره للمنظمات
العالميه من حيث النمو الاقتصادي وكانت
تتحدث المنظمات من دون النصف الثاني من
العام 20 22 يتحدثون بان المملكه ستحقق
اقوى نمو اقتصاده في العالم 2020 ذكر
دكتور ان اسعار الطاقه كان لها دور كبير
في نمو الاقتصادي في السعوديه طب ما انا
انخفضت هذه الاسعار لان احنا نعلم انه
اسعار الطاقه ليست ثابته هل راحت تاثر في
هذا النمو الاقتصاد السعودي نعم من المرجح
الان في العام 20 22 نتحدث عن ثلاثه ولا
واحد في المئه نمو 20 24
5.2% وفي عام 20 25 يتحدث عن اربعه ونصف
انا اعتقد بان الاوضاع الجيوش سياسيه الان
الموجوده كفيله بان تجعل اسعار النفط
حقيقه في ارتفاع ما لم يحدث اغلاقات في
الصين نلاحظ الان بان ارقام عدد كورونا او
الحالات في ازدياد والى الان الحكومه
الصينيه لم تتخذ اي اجراء اتجاه هذا الامر
ولكن بخلاف هذا الامر انا اعتقد بان النمو
الاقتصادي سيضل ثابت وجهه نظري بان ثلاثه
فاصله واحد في المئه هو نموم متحفظ بشكل
كبير اعتقد بان الارقام ستصل الى اعلى من
هذا لذلك نحن مرشحون المملكه يعني حقيقه
اللي تحقيق نمو اقتصادي ربما يتجاوز ثلاثه
فاصله واحده الدكتور اللي يمكن ان ترتكز
عليها او يرتكز عليها الاقتصاد السعودي
للاستمرار في هذا النمو هذا المستوى من
النمو الاقتصاد نعم انا اعتقد بان اولا
اسعار ستلعب دور مهم ايضا هناك رفعه
معدلات الفائده المملكه طبعا هي تربط
الريال بالدولار وهذا يعني سياسه نقديه
شدد ولكن المملكه ما يقابل هذه السياسه
النقديه المتشدده هي سياسه ماليه توسعيه
وهذا يعني بان المملكه سترفع نسب الفائده
ولكن في نفس الوقت سيكون هناك انفاق حكومي
انفاق استثناء انفاق استيل استثماري على
مستوى الشركه وايضا انفاق استهلاك كل هذه
الثلاثه ونحن نعلم بان معادله النمو
الاقتصادي هي تاتي من الانفاق الاستهلاكي
زائدا الانفاق الاستثماري زائر الى
الانفاق الحكومي زائدا الوارث الصادرات
ناقصنا الواردات لذلك الصادرات ستكون
مرتفعه الانفاق الحكومي سيكون مرتفع
الانفاق الاستثماري سيكون مرتفع ولكن ربما
هو اقل من الانفاق الاستهلاك كلام كبير
هالحكي كيف ممكن يؤثر على حياه المواطن
والمقيم في السعوديه انا اعتقد بانه وجود
النمو الاقتصادي وميزانيه لان نتحدث عن
ميزانيه للعام 2020 هي ميزانيه انفاقيه
هذا يعني بان الحكومه ستظلتهم فقه هذا
يعني بان العجله الاقتصاديه في المشاريع
والقطاع الخاص يعني والان عندنا جزء من
القطاع الخاص هو يعتمد على الانفاق
الحكومي في المشاريع الكبيره استمرار
المشاريع الجيجا بروجكت وايضا المشاريع
هذا يعني بان القطاع الخاص سيتنفع تنفع
القطاع الخاص يعني بان التوظيف سيزيد هذا
سيعني بان الايرادات ستزيد للقطاع الخاص
سينعكس بشكل ايجابي على مستوى المستهلك
وايضا على على مستوى المواطن وعلى مستوى
المقيم ايضا طيب شكرا لك في الاستديو
الكاتب الاقتصادي الدكتور علي الحازمي
شكرا لانضمامك لنا
اعربت وزاره الخارجيه الكويتيه في بيان
لها عن استيائها ورفضها لاعتداء رجال
الامن المصريين على طلبه كويتيين لفضي
الخلاف بينهم حيث تم الافراج عن جميع
الطلبه بعد تواصل نائب وزير الخارجيه
الكويتيه مع السفير المصري في الكويت
مطالبا بسرعه قيام السلطات المصريه باتخاذ
الاجراءات القانونيه والرسميه بما يكفل
حقوق الطلبه
شو تتابعونا بعد الفاصل
مستشفى التخصصي في الرياض يكشف عن عمليتي
زراعه قلبين لطفلتين خلال 24 ساعه
مشاريع الشرقيه بموقع استراتيجي فريد في
مدينه الخبر جنوب منطقه العزيزيه بمساحتها
الرحمه واطلالتها البهيه على طريق الملك
فهد رؤى رؤيه تواكب شغف الاستثمار
الجديد بيدخل لعمق السنه
يقلل من حساسيه الاسنان امسح الاشخاص انهم
ما يهملوا مشكله حساسيه الاسنان
ان اول تنظيم للاخوان المسلمين في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه كان عام
1937 للميلاد بماذا يعرف
الفلسفي لحركات الاسلاميه
حتى تتاح لهم الفرصه
برصدك اللي توغل هذه الجماعات في قطاع
التعليم الى اي حد اصبحوا متنفذين ومتولين
او متحكمين الاخوان التنظيم العام لم يعد
لهم قبول بالذات في المملكه النائب وزير
الشؤون الاسلاميه
الخامسه والنصف على شاشه العربيه
سهله سهله مره
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد
واسعا لمقاطع فيديو غرق جزء من احد
المشاريع السكنيه بمياه الامطار
اسبوع المطر على عاصمه الرياض وباقي المدن
السعوديه كشف المستوره عن بعض مشاريع
التطوير العقاري حيث تداول مستخدم مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي لمشاهده فيلا سكنيه
غارقه في المياه باحد مشاريع تطوير
العقاري مستوى المياه هذا المرتفع
مشاهدينا دفع الدفاع المدني الى اخلاء
سكان تلك المنازل باستخدام القوارب كما
نشاهد في هذا الفيديو والمتداول قصه الحي
الذي غرق بالمياه شهد تفاعلا واسعا
مشاهدينا على منصات التواصل حيث ابدا
المستخدمون تعجبهم مما يحصلوا في مثل تلك
المشاريع وطالبوا بمستوى جودتهم اعلى
الشركه المطوره للمشروع العقاريات الى
اصدار بيان قالت فيه بان التضرر كان جزئيا
ولم يصل كافه انحاء المشروع كما قالت بان
شبكه السيول تم تسليمها لامانه الرياض
مشدده على ان مخططات البنيه التحتيه
للمشروع تم تنفيذها وفقا للمخططات معتمدام
على الجانب الاخر تداول مستخدم مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي مقاطع فيديو لمشروع
سدره تابع لشركه روشن للتطوير العقاري
والمملوكه لصندوق الاستثمارات السعوديه
حيث كشف الفيديو عن خلو الحي من اي تجمعات
لمياه الامطار نتيجه البنيه التحتيه
المنفذه وكان ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان قد ذكر في مقابله اجراها في
ابريل من عام 20 و 21 بانه خمسه وتسعين في
المئه من المطورين العقاريين بدائي
للاسف يعني بقول لك اكثر من 65 مطورين
العقاريين في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بدون اي خدمات يشتري المواطن يبني بيته
ونبدا نعاني من المواطن يطلب كل الخدمات
حفريات شوارع سيئه سيئه خدمات سيئه في
الحي ما في شكل البلد في حاجه الى مطور
عقاري قوي جدا يضع على ستاندر بحيث القطاع
الخاص اذا اراد يطول يطول بنفس استعداد
الطبيعي اللي يعمل في الدول المتقدمه في
انحاء العالم وهذا كان هدف الثاني لشركه
المزيد ينضم الينا في الاستوديو دكتور
ماجد حلواني وكيل كليه العماره والتخطيط
للدراسات العليا في جامعه الملك سعود اهلا
بك معنا الدكتور في استديوهات العربيه
بالرياض بقريه دكتور خلينا نحكي عن معايير
تطوير الاحياء يعني الى اي مداهيه قابله
للتنفيذ والى اي مدى شركات تطوير الاحياء
هي قادره على تنفيذها
في الاحياء السكنيه تطويرها في السابق ما
كان في معايير
تصميميه فالان طبعا الوزاره وزاره القرويه
والاسكان
الاشكاليه وبدات طلع معايير لتصميم الحياه
السكنيه ويمكن نحن شفنا الان يعني في شركه
روشن طلعت وعندنا تجارب سابقه طبعا عندنا
يعني اقدم تجربه الجبيل ينبع تجربه تصميم
او تخطيط الاحياء السكنيه في الجبال ينبع
ناجحه جدا حي السفارات واحد من التجارب
الناجحه كذلك فاعتقد يمكن في الفتره
القادمه ان شاء الله مع وجود الاكواد
العمرانيه فحل نشاهد يعني يمكن حل كبير
للمشاكل
الامطار الغزيره دكتور يعني خرجت الشركه
المطوره كامله
اكبر الخلل احيانا عندنا الاشكاليه بتكون
مكفيه وجود التصميم الحيه السكني وموقع
الحياه السكني طبعا في دراسه في التخطيط
العمراني والتصميم العمراني ان احنا نعمل
دراسات اسماء دراسات التحليل الموقع
فواحده من الحاجات المهمه نعرف نحنا في
دراسات تحليل الموقع موقع الحي هل موقع
الحي يقع في اوديه او لا مجاري السيول او
لا هذه واحده من المعايير المهمه جدا قبل
تصميم الحيه السكريه من الدكتور
العقاري
فهذه كل من سوريا تقع على الاثنين لكن
البلديه هي الاساس وهي اللي تقع عليها
المساجد في هذه المنطقه بالضبط
هل هي قادره على احتواء هذه الامطار
الغزيره قادره على منع هذه التجمعات
للمياه يعني قصدي تركيزها على البنت تحتيه
للاحياء تحديدا طبعا توسع الشبكه يمكن
يعني بناء الشبكه او البنيه التحتيه اللي
تصريف مياه الامطار في يوم من الايام اذا
كانت كميه الامطار اكثر من استيعاب الشبكه
هيصبح عندنا انهيار النظام كامل فبالتالي
هتحصل المشكله كامله
فاحيانا الشبكه ما بتصمم حسب كميه المياه
اللي متوقع انها تسقط طبعا نحن في
الدراسات اللي نعملها عندنا كميه امطار كل
25 سنه نتوقعها كل 50 سنه وكل مائه سنه
فاحيانا الدراسات ما بتكون عملت بطريقه
صحيحه
من الحاجات اللي بدانا نشوف احنا الان في
مدن السعوديه ممكن على مستوى العالم كلها
كميه الامطار بدات تتغير
والمعادلات اصبحت اعلى من السفر
الان اختلفت هذه المعايير فما الحلول
عندنا همم اعاده تصميم توسيع البنيه
التحتيه الشبكه البنيه التحتيه او ازاله
الاحياء السكنيه اذا كانت تقع طبعا في
مجال السيول فهذا واحد من الحلول الصعبه
يعني بس لابد منها اذا كانت في مجال
السيول وايضا قلت لي دكتور لما حكينا خلف
الهواء انه عندك في جامعه الملك سعود
دورات ودبلومات وماجستير ايضا للمراقبين
لتطوير الاحياء وتطوير البناء والمشاريع
والاسكان واحده منها البرنامج الدبلوم علي
في التخطيط والتصميم الحضاري يهتم طبعا
بتحسين المشهد الحضاري وكل هذه حتى تصب في
تحسين جوده الحياه او رفع مستوى جوده
الحياه يوجد برنامج اخر لجامعه الملك سعود
الان بتعمل فيه مع الوزاره همم البرنامج
يهتم بالمراقبين الرفع من المستوى
المراقبين دورات همم قصيره
والهدف هو طبعا تحسين المشهد الحضري
ومعالجه الشوهات المصريه اللي موجوده في
المدن السعوديه ممتاز شكرا لك في الاستديو
الدكتور ماجد حلواني وكيل كليه العماره
والتخطيط الدراسات العليا في جامعه الملك
سعود اشكرك
في السعوديه نجح فريق جراحه قلب الاطفال
بمستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي ومركز الابحاث
بالرياض في زراعه قلبين لطفلتين خلال 24
ساعه وذلك بعد اشهر من اعتمادهما على مضخه
اصطناعيه بسبب عدم توفر المتبرعين حيث
انتقل الفريق الى مكه لازاله قلب متبرع
متوفى والعوده به الى الرياض لزراعته
لطفله سعوديه يبلغ عمرها 19 شهرا ثم
الانتقال الى اماره دبي لاجراء عمليه اخرى
لازاله قلب من متبرع متوفي في الامارات
والعوده به الى الرياض وزراعته في الرياض
لطفله اماراتيه تعد اصغر حاله تخضع لعمليه
زراعه قلب على مستوى الشرق الاوسط
ينضم الي هاتفيا رئيس قسم القلب للاطفال
بمستشفى الملك فيصل واحد اعضاء الفريق
الطبي للعمليه دكتور محمد الهبدان اهلا بك
معنا دكتور يعطيكم العافيه الصراحه او
مبروك نجاح هذه العمليتين لزراعه القلبين
للطفلتين
الضوء
الطبيه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
للانتقال من مكه الى الرياض الى دبي ثم
الرياض مجددا خلال فقط 24 ساعه لزراعه قلب
بين كيف كانت هذه الرحله دكتوره
طبعا هذه الرحله تعتبر
كوادر طبيه عاليه التدريب وباعداد ليست
بالقليل عن اجراء هذه العمليات المعقده
خلال 24 ساعه كان في مستشفى الملك
يعانون من فشل عضله القلب ويحتاجون الى
زراعه للقلب فبعد مدير شهرين وجودهم على
مضخه القلب الصناعي يتوفر قلب في مكه
المكرمه الفريق
بالخدمات العاديه الموجوده فقام بنقل
القلب المتبرع به من مكه الى جده ثم
بالاخلاق طبي الى الرياض وزراعته في طفله
السعوديه عمرها 19 19 شهر
فقط خلال اقل من 24 ساعه كان هناك ايضا
القلب الصناعي
وخدمات عاليه بالتنسيق مع المركز زراعه
الاعضاء المبارات العربي
الى اماره دبي واحضار القلب
اماراتيه الصغيره
وتبرى اصغر طفل تمت زراعه له القلب في
الشرق الاوسط بيعتبر انجازا عاليا جدا
واحده لدينا الحفظ لله مثل هذه الاجراءات
والعمليات دكتور ما المتطلبات اللي
تحتاجها وانا اتحدث من بنا تحتيه طبيه من
كوادر ذات ذو خبره ماذا تحتاجون للقيام
بعمليات كبيره مثل هذا الحجم
عمليات القلبيه في اعمار صغيره
في جميع مراكز زراعه القلب بالعالم هناك
مراكز متفرقه بذلك بسبب الصعوبات
فيها احجار صغيره
هناك طاقم طبي متكامل في مختلف التخصص
بيا هو طبيه مساعده لاجراء هذه العمليات
فايضا لابد من التواصل الخدمات اللوجستيه
العاليه من ناحيه المراكز التنظيميه التي
تقوم بالتنسيق لعمليات الزراعه
كملرجعيه مركزيه وكره الاخلاء الطبي
الكوادر المؤهله
بشكل سريع لانه هناك ساعات
الاخلاق الذي ينتقل اه يقوم بحرب همم
الكوادر الطبيه ومن ثم العوده مباشره
وبشراء عاليه اذا ابيض لعامليه الزراعه
وفي نفس الوقت هنا تحديه اخر وهو خلال اقل
من 24 ساعه تحتاج ان تكون انتقائي
بالانتقال الى دوله اخرى زياره العضو
المتضرره المتبرع به المتفجره فيها الطفله
الاماراتيه التي تحتاج الى هذا الى هذا
القلب
اسمح لي اسالك الاجراءات هذه يعني تتحدث
انت عن اخلاء طبي عن سفر خارج السعوديه
والعوده لابد انها اجراءات وتاخذ وقت طويل
كيف التمسك ثلاثه تجاوب بسرعه التجاوب
لاتخاد مثل هذه الاجراءات خصوصا انك قلت
ان الوقت حساس
نعم طبعا هناك اللجان للتنسيق
والتقدم الموجوده بين الحمد لله سهل من
هذه الاجراءات فهناك مراكز تقوم بحصل
المعلومات عن المتبرعين
والتواصل بشكل مباشر مع المراكز الطبيه
التي تحتوي على عمليه الزراعه ف- اا عمليه
التنسيق بينهم سريع لانه هذا يدل على
الاحترافيه
هي العاليه الجمله التي تخدم مثل هذه
شكرا لك رئيس قسم القلب للاطفال في مستشفى
الملك فيصل واحد اعضاء الفريق الطبي
للعمليه الدكتور محمد الهبدان على هذه
المداخله
توصلوا وزاره الصحه في السعوديه رعايه
المرضى غير القادرين على الوصول للمنشات
الصحيه من من تنطبق عليهم شروط الرعايه
الصحيه المنزليه وتقديم الخدمات العلاجيه
لهم وذلك بهدف تحسين جوده حياه المرضى
الصحيه حيث سجلت اكثر من
881000 زياره للمرضى في العام 20 22
المزيد مع علي اللغبي
[موسيقى]
خدمته طبيه متعدده تقدمها وزاره الصحه في
السعوديه في المرضى المستحقين في منازلهم
ضمن خدمه رعايه الصحيه المنزليه التي
تعتبر من ابرز البرامج الخدميه في القطاع
الصحي لتقليل تواجد المرضى وتخفيف عبيت
تنقلهم الى المستشفيات برنامج الرعايه
الصحيه المنزليه يعنى بالاشخاص
ممن لديهم امراض او وضعهم الصحي يمنعهم من
مراجعه العيادات الخارجيه او المستشفيات
واي خدمه رعايه شموليه همم تتضمن الرعايه
التمريضيه والطبيه والعلاج الطبيعي
والارشاد الاجتماعي والنفسي وغيرها من
الخدمات الصحيه
بحسب وزاره الصحه بلغ عدد الزيارات التي
نفذتها في العام 2022 اكثر من 881
الفيزياره للمرضى غير القادرين على الحركه
وكبار السن في منازلهم من خلال 516 فرقا
طبيا
و538 سياره طبيه مجهزه باحداث التقنيات
استفاد منها نحو
66,384 مريضا في 250 مستشفى ومدينه طبيه
في جميع المناطق فيما بلغ عدد المرضى
المسجلين بالخدمه للعام 2022
49 الفريق
المستشفى الجنه
شغاله وزوجته
اكثر
واحنا ان شاء الله متمكنين في خدمتها طبعا
هذه
هذا شيء يسعدنا ويبسطنا نحن نقدم لهم
الخدمه وهم في منازلهم ان شاء الله يكونوا
مرتاحين لا تتوقفوا الرعايه الصحيه
المنزليه على تقديم الخدمات الطبيه للمرضى
في منازلهم بل تمتد الى الوقوف على
الجوانب الاجتماعيه والنفسيه والتاكدين من
ملاءمه البيئه المنزليه بما يضمن تقديما
رعايه صحيه شامله للمرضى في منازلهم من
المنطقه الشرقيه علي اللغبي العربيه
[موسيقى]
نبقى في السعوديه حيث اطلقت امانه المنطقه
الشرقيه اليوم المرحله الاولى لمبادره
تصوير 169 ارضا من الاراضي الفضاء في
محافظه القطيف و سيتم خلالها الزام ملاك
الاراضي الواقعه ضمن المحاور المستهدفه
بالتسويق قبل المهله المحدده وهي الاول من
مارس لهذا العام وستضم اللوائح متطلبات
اهمها ان يقام السور على حدود الملكيه
للارض الفضاء وان يتم تنفيذه على جميع
حدود الارض ووفق تصميما موحد ويسمحوا بفتح
بوابه للسور على ان يكون مالك الارض
مسؤولا تماما عن سلامه رصيف المشاه
والاناره والتشجير ان وجدت اثناء التنفيذ
[موسيقى]
اصدر المركز الاحصائيه لدول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي ملخصا يوضح مؤشرات الاحصاءات
الاسكانيه والتي زادت في دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي خلال عام 20 21 مقارنه بعام 2017
[موسيقى]
شو تتابعونا بعد الفاصل ايضا
الرابعه تتجول في العلا وتنقل ابرز
الفعاليات المقامه للسياح
الملايين سموا ومرحله التصوير لمنال على
اعلى نسب تسميات بدات الان صوت عبر تطبيق
جوي اوورز لواحد من المرشحين الاربعه عن
كل فئه من فئه السينما المسلسلات الموسيقى
الرياضه ومواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]
التسجيل عبر التطبيق لتكون احد الفائزين
العشره بفرصه الفوز لتذكارتين لحضور هذا
الهدف الضخم مع ضيف من اختياره لتعيش ليله
فوق الخيال وتشاهد لحظه تكريم نجومكم
المفضلين
نتائج التصويت تعلن خلال حفل توزيع جوائز
صناع الترفيه جوي اوورز في الحادي
والعشرين من يناير لعام 2023 مباشره من
الرياض
فسارع بالتصويت الان لان صوتك انت هو
الحاسب
تطبيق جوي اورك متوفر على اب ستور وجوجل
بلاي
[موسيقى]
القسطره القلبيه العلاجيه
وجراحات القلب على مداري 24 ساعه
بمستشفيات المواساه
المواساه خبره تنبض بالثقه
[موسيقى]
العربيه
احييكم من جديد ومباشره الى العلا التي
تجتذب سنويا الاف السياح من داخل وخارج
السعوديه حيث اصبحت العلا احدى الواجهات
المفضله للسياح خصوصا مع البرامج
والفعاليات التي تحتضنها المحافظه والتي
من ابرزها احتفال طنطوره
تنضم الينا من العلا منفذت العربيه نادين
خماش اهلا بك معنا نادين على نشره الرابعه
تطلين علينا من قلعه العلا على ما يبدو
حدثنا عنها نادين
نشره الرابعه اقف الان من قلعه العلا اقف
بين حجاره تحكي تاريخا وحضاره هذه القلعه
التي حينما تم الكشف عن اثارها ودراسه
اساساتها تعود الى الحضاره اللحيانيه يعني
نتحدث عن 700 سنه قبل الميلاد هذه
الاساسات التي وجدت وبنيت هنا في هذه
المنطقه طبعا قلعه العلاه تطل على البلده
القديمه في العلا هذه القلعه بنيت من باب
المراقبه وايضا لمراقبه قوافل الحجيج
ولتامين دخول وعبور المارين والعابرين الى
البلده القديمه وهذه هي كانت اساس الهدف
من هذه القلعه قلعه العلاج لكن الان بما
انه هي نقطه مرتفعه فبالتالي اصبحت مطل
اصبحت مساحه فيها الزوار من كل مكان لكي
يقف هنا هو يناظر البلده القديمه طبعا
فاطمه كما تشاه هذه البيوت المتراصه هي
بيوت البلده القديمه البلده القديمه تحوي
اكثر من 900 مبلغ هذه المباني مشيده
بالبيوت الطينيه وطبعا ما زالت قيد
الترميم ونتابع معكم هذه البيوت اشبه
بمتاهه همم عندما تدخل من بيت الى اخر لكن
اذا اردت ان نذهب ونشاهد هنا هذا الحي ما
جد اذا نشاهد الحي من منطقه اليمين هذه
البيوت يعني الجديده كما ترونها من منطقه
اليمين هذه البيوت هي منطقه الجديدا
المتواجد هناك هذه هي البلده القديمه وهنا
قلعه العلا نتحدث عن مساحه تقريبا 180 متر
مربع وفاطمه كمان يجب ان يشير الى انه اذا
اراد شخص ان يصل من البلده القديمه الى
قلعه العلا هو يحتاج لكي يصعد 190 درجه
درجه ثم درجه بالتالي انا العربيه صعدنا
190 درجه حتى نصل الى هذا المكان
لهذا اليوم نادين
ممارسه الرياضه اكيد منهم منذ الساعه
السادسه صباحا نحن نمارس الرياضه لانه نحن
هنا في تغطيه ايضا لصباح العربيه وسيكون
لدينا ايضا تغطيه يوم غد من قلب البلده
القديمه في العلا ايضا فاطمه نريد ان نشير
ونذكر مره اخرى لان البلده القديمه في
العلا صنفت من واحده من افضل الكره
السياحيه العالميه لعام 20 22 طبعا هناك
معايير محدده يتم تحديدها لاي لتقييم اي
قريه لتصنف من الواجهات واحدى القرى
العالميه السياحيه من بينها الاستدامه
وايضا هناك تركيز كبير على فكره الاستدامه
في هذه القريه هناك جهود كبيره لاعاده
ترميمها وتطويرها لكي تصبح واجهه ثقافيه
واجهه سياحيه لزوار العلا سواء من اهلها
سواء من اهل داخل المملكه العربيه
السعوديه داخل
البلده القديمه التي اصبحت ممتلئه
بالمتاجر والمقاهي والمطاعم بكثره السياحه
المتواجدين فيها شكرا لك من العلم وفدت
العربيه نادين خماش
مباراه المنتخب بين العراقي والسعودي في
اطار منافسات بطوله خليجي 25 في البصره
تمتاز هذه المره بطابع مختلف وبعيد عن
نتيجه هذه المواجهه الكرويه عبرت عنه
الصحافه والمشجعون في البلدين منتظر
الرشيد
طيب الانطلاقى مباراه المنتخبين العراقي
والسعودي في ايطاليا منافسات بطوله خليجي
سالنا مجموعه من الصحفيين السعوديين
والمشجعين ايضا الذين يتواجدون في هذا
المكان عن توقعاتهم لنتيجه هذه المباراه
المباراه السعوديه والعراق اعتقد اعتقد
انها اقرب للتعادل خصوصا يعني اذا ما
نظرنا المستوى المنتخب السعودي وايضا عامل
الارض والجمهور للمنتخب العراقي في
المحصله النهائيه هو التقاء الاشقاء
المنتخب العراقي والمنتخب السعودي هو
بذاته بطوله مستقله عن بطوله كاس الخليج
الى المباراه
والاهم من المباراه متعه المشاهد يعني
تنظمت هذه همم الدوره على اساس المشاهد
يستمتع
انا اتوقع ان اثنين واحد لصالح السعوديه
خاصه انه الموضوع اكبر واعمق من موضوع كاس
او فرحه او فوز الموضوع اخوه ترابط اما
بالنسبه للصحفيين العراقيين والمشجعين
ايضا الذين ساهم عن توقعاتهم لنتيجه هذه
المباراه فكانت اجاباتهم لا تختلف كثيرا
عن نظرائهم في المملكه المباراه ستكون
تنافسيه الجماهير العراقيه ستشجع العراق
والسعوديه حضور السعوديه الى العراق لا
يعني داخل المستطيل الاخضر خارج المستطيل
الاخضر اهم العراق يحتاج الى الفوز حتى
يحسنعها السعوديه قد تلعب بشكل مرتاح اكثر
اتوقع ان هذه المباراه تميل الى تعادل
ثاني قد تقصي العراق من البطوله وتبقي
السعوديه في المنافسات وانا شخصيا اتوقع
ولا اتوقع انما اتمنى ان تفوز السعوديه
لان اريد لهذا الكاس ان يكون خليجيا وليس
عراقيه على اعتبار انه العراق قد فاز بكاس
التنظيم شكرا بعيدا عن نتيجه هذه المباراه
يؤكد جمهور الفريقين وجود الكثيره من
رسائل الاخوه والتلاحم في هذا اللقاء
الكروي ابعد بكثير عن الجوانب الفنيه من
البصره منتظر رشيد العربيه
شهد سوق الزل في الرياض اقبالا واسعا من
المواطنين والسياح لشراء المشاريع الصوفيه
والفراء بالتزامن مع تواصل انخفاض درجه
الحراره في مختلف مناطق السعوديه هذا
وتختلف الفراء في اشكالها وانواعها كما هي
اسعارها والتي قد تصل الى اكثر من 4000
ريال
ينضم الينا من سوق الزل بالرياض مراسل
العربيه هاني الصياد اهلا بك معنا هاني
انقل لنا الصوره لديكم سوق الزل بالرياض
يه طبعا من اقدم سوق شعبي في وسط العاصمه
الرياض وهو سوق الزل وتحديدا الذي الان
بدا في وصول او ايضا زياره العديد من
الزبائن وكذلك السياح له بهدف اقتناء همم
الفراء او الفرو او المشاعله الصوفيه خاصه
في ظل انخفاض درجات الحراره التي تشهدها
مناطق السعوديه طبعا انواع عديده من
الفراسه وفن نشاهدها ولكن هنا عديد من
المحلات التي تقوم
همم البضائع وكذلك من المشارح الصوفيه
وايضا السديريات الصوفيه وايضا المنتجات
من انواع الفرق سواء الطفيليه او ما تسمى
نوع الطفيلي او كذلك
من نوع همم او من فراء الارانب وايضا الى
اجانب المشاعله الصوفيه طبعا معي مساعد
المجاهد مجرم مجاهد عفوا مقرن المجاهد يا
مرحبا يمسيكم الله بالخير يعني انت احد
المحلات واحد اصحاب الخبره في الفراق
اليوم نتكلم عن فرات تصل سعرها الى اكثر
من 4,500 ريال صحيح هذا الامر هذا النوع
القماش الكشميري وطفيلي العالي
باربعه باربعه و5 في شيء ب
3000,500 وفيها انواع الصناعي اللي يبدا
من 500 طيب
هذا
صغير وهذا القباب بشت قماش
اليوم سوق سوق الفراء والمشالح الصوفيه في
السعوديه كيف نقدرها
اللهم لك الحمد كم حجم السوق تقريبا في
موضوع القراءه
ومتوفر والحمد لله والصناعه وطنيه اغلب
صنع وطنيه
[موسيقى]
من جميع الدول
هذا نوع الترمه طيب
هذا نوع الترم هذا الشاتوسه
بدل الشماغ في موسم الشتاء نعم هذا يلبس
ويدفيس
الى 300 500 2015
ااا هناك في ازدياد وهذا هو الوضع هنا في
السعوديه من خلال الوصول او ايضا زياده في
اعداد المنتجات لهذه
المنتجات الشتويه من خلال ايضا همم ايضا
هناك استقبال كبير او هناك زوارك كثر
الخارجي
يعد وادي الرمه اطول واشهر واد في الجزيره
العربيه ومن اهم الظواهر الطبيعيه في
الجزيره العربيه التفاصيل في تقويم مع
خالد ازعاج
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعظم واطول واشهر وادي في الجزيره العربيه
وهو الاوحد الذي يقطعها من الغرب الى
الشرق هو وادي الرمه وهو من الظواهر
الطبيعيه عندنا ففي العصور المطيره كان
نهرا جاريا من مرتفعات الحجاز الى شط
العرب وفي العصر التصحر قطعه اوصاله
الرمال فتحول الى ثلاثه اجزاء وادي الرمه
وادي الاجردي وادي الباطن وفي عصر الجفاف
تحول الى نهر جاف ينهض ثلاث مرات كل مئه
سنه ومع تغيرات المناخيه بدا يجري العلا
فترات متقاربه سر لا تقف في الدرب ولا
ياتي اليه والحلم لا يجري ليسقط في يديه
هي هكذا الايام سعي دائم ان تلتفت
للخلف تخسر ما لديك
[تصفيق]
ومجرى وادي الرمه كان احد طرق التجاره
العالميه
قديما والرابطه بين اسيا وافريقيا وجريانه
له فوائد عده اهمها يجدد خصوبه الارض
ويغذي الابار ويخفف ملوحتها الملح يصلح كل
ما يخشى عليه من الفساد فاذا الفساد جرى
عليه فحكمه
حكم الرماد
[موسيقى]
نذكر بالعناوين
القضاء الايراني يصدر احكاما بالسجن ضد
اربعه متهمين بالدعوه للاضراب
صحيفه بلومبرج تقول بان الاقتصاد السعودي
قد يحقق اسرع اقتصادات العالم نموا على
حساب الهند
تجمع مياه الامطار داخل احياء سكنيه في
السعوديه يجدد مطالب رفعه معايير تنفيذ
مشاريع بناها التحتيه
ومستشفى التخصصي بالرياض يكشف عن عامليتي
زراعه قلبين لطفلتين خلال 24 ساعه
مركز الاحصاء الخليجي يكشف عن انخفاض عدد
سكان دول الخليج بمليون نسمه خلال عام
نهايه الرابعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]